cmt awards to me
are it's like the party of country music
especially after this last crazy year
it's gonna be lit literally i think my
favorite thing about hosting last year
um was my first time gonna do anything
like that i felt like my suit was cool
this year kane is joined by first time
co-host kelsey
for the two and a half hour show live
from nashville
we've only really hung out today so this
is fun
having a fan voted award show is a whole
different ball game
you carry are the most awarded artists
in cmt
history with 22 wins i was voted
into this whole life you know being
being on american idol cmt queen carey
earned two more nods this year
for her duet with john legend including
the coveted
video of the year
what it means continuing the winning
streak if you will
i'm always about padding the numbers now
miss underwood is one of the 32
performers
debbie barrett was supposed to take the
stage but just backed out
because of personal circumstances maren
morris also pulled out due to a
scheduling conflict both marin and
miranda lambert
are the night's most nominated artists
each up for four awards
i think we're all just ready to play the
fact that there's stuff happening and
live music is coming back we're
just thrilled to be part of that other
big moments to watch for
a four-time grammy winner her will make
her cmt debut
performing with chris stapleton
seven-time grammy winner gladys knight
is doing a duet with mickey guyton and
lauren elena will be rocking out with
john party
there's nothing in the entire world i
want more than to be back on the road
playing for live audiences thank you cmt
awards
thank you jesus thank you john party
over
him god
you